so just explain what this amendment is
all about and do you think you've got
the numbers to win
it's all about mps having a vote on the
government's policy before it comes into
force and takes away people's civil
liberties
so members of parliament are feeling
increasingly helpless as their
constituents complain about real impacts
on their lives their jobs their
prosperity
indeed their health which come from the
side effects of covet measures
so we're not proposing to take the power
from ministers to decide what's done or
take away the power of the business of
the house of commons none of those worst
fears we're just saying
that the government should use the
procedure that puts a statutory
instrument before the house
for a debate and the decision in a sense
i'm saying mps
should be sharing in the dreadful burden
of decision in these circumstances
and not just retrospectively being asked
to approve what the government's done
and to ask answer your question
there are plenty of mps who would vote
uh for this amendment if it is selected
and we think it will be selected
it's really down to labor the snp and
the liberal democrats
if it comes to it i have to say we don't
really want a rebellion
we're trying to support the government
in getting this done by saying
let us vote on these measures and
support the government let's have policy
which enjoys our consent
so if the opposition parties do back the
amendment labor the
dems etc do you think you've got the
numbers to get it through i'm
well i'm certain at the moment but that
that's really as i say we would prefer
to avoid
this coming to a division i'm afraid
it's in the nature of the way parliament
works that things happen like this
but i'm i back boris johnson i want him
to succeed
but we do need to share with the
government the burden of decision on
these measures and not just
come in you know days or weeks later
retrospectively perhaps voting on
measures which have subsequently been
amended it's been a nonsense you know
you look at the public health act 1984
measures came in by the time we voted on
them they'd been changed once or twice
and we had charles walker former head of
the procedure committee he wouldn't mind
me saying
you know stood up in the house of
commons and wasn't sure which measure he
was voting on well if somebody who's
chaired the procedure committee
can't be sure well then we're into a
nonsense position where
mp's democratic consent for really
important draconian policy
has ended up being missing so we're
trying to put this right and actually
it's a very modest proposal
that mps should vote on law before it
comes into effect and takes away
people's liberties
you say it's a modest proposal you say
you're trying to share the burden but at
the same time if there's anything that
the last two six months or so has told
us
it's how fast this virus can move is
there not a risk
that your amendment effectively slows
the government down
it stops it from taking that very quick
action which might be necessary in the
fight against covert 19.
well we need a solution that does allow
for that fast and effective action which
also rules out any possibility of
mischief from the labour party but which
also gives mps
ordinarily the opportunity to vote
before things come into action but i
think if you if everybody reflects on
what
has happened the prime minister's made
announcements about what's to come into
a
in into effect days later there really
has been time now
for measures to be properly debated i
think at the time we put the coronavirus
act through
you could see that it was an emergency
in the reasonable worst case of the time
we needed to just get that act through
and it was an
awful thing to face but now we're much
further along
now treatments have improved now there's
more testing there
is time to have a debate on a statutory
instrument we're only really talking
about a two hour debate
on a statutory instrument with no
amendments to that instrument that's the
way it works
vote on it if if parliament votes for it
then the minister can sign it into law
and this is the normal procedure
and i think we need to reach an
agreement with the government whereby if
it was a genuine emergency they could
act on
what's called the maid affirmative
procedure but i'm afraid this is very
procedural but
there is a really is a scope here to
solve the problem we've done it before
with the eu withdrawal act we can do it
now
um i'm interested to get your thoughts a
bit more broadly
on some of the measures and the
direction that the government is going
in i noticed you used the word draconian
in the interview a bit earlier you
previously said uh it's time for us to
actually start living like a free people
not subjecting ourselves to constantly
shifting
legal requirements what exactly do you
mean what are your concerns
well a hundred acts of parliament have
been used to put in place i think it's
242 statutory instruments
the telegraph has reported i think it
was yesterday that there have been 200
changes well when you've got a body of
law
that large changing that fast i doubt
really anyone understands what that law
is
much beyond the people who wrote the
frequently asked questions available on
the gov
uk website which now run to 22 pages
when you print them
so we're in an environment where you
really can't know whether you're a
criminal or not
with this much law coming into force and
changing so fast
and that's why i've said this is not a
fit environment for free people
you know being so you don't feel that
we're being treated like a free people
at the minute
that's what i'm saying absolutely yes i
mean how do people think that liberty
dies it dies like this with with
government exercising draconian powers
without parliamentary scrutiny in
advance undermining the rule of law by
having a shifting blanket of rules that
no one can understand
i mean it's extremely serious i don't
think i look like a hysterical person to
you
i'm saying that this is a very serious
moment rishi sunak brought up this issue
that we need to learn to live without
fear at the moment moment the public are
being deliberately told
measure told that they should be afraid
the idea i think the phrase used was
that the sense of personal risk needed
to be raised well the government's been
frightening people into compliance and
it hasn't been working
if you look at figures from king's
college the figures for
how the proportion of people isolating
if they've got covid
symptoms are very low i think it's 18
you know this
this isn't working trying to frighten
people and actually what we need to do
is all grow up
and try and live a bit more virtuously
have a bit more faith hope courage
temperance prudence all those great
virtues which actually make a society
one worth having
so that's why i want government to come
to parliament
give mps a vote before things come into
effect and let us share in the burden of
decision and represent our constituents
which is what we're elected to do at the
same time though
infection numbers are going one way at
the minute and
all the evidence suggests that the
government has actually got the public's
backing on a lot of the restrictions
that it's put in place according to a
yougov survey this week
78 of people support the government's
new measures so are you actually on the
wrong side of the argument
here well no but this is the thing about
surveys
versus what people actually do and i
know what the surveys say and i also
know
what the king's college evidence says
about compliance i'm afraid there is a
disconnect between people's intentions
and what they actually do and that
that's really what i'm
pointing to i'm well aware of the case
numbers going up and i'm well aware that
this is a
dangerous disease for people with
comorbidities but i'm also well aware
that for people under the age of 60
without other pre-existing conditions it
is not an especially dangerous disease
and this is one of the cruelties of it
so i'm very interested in listening to
your debate between scientists
scientists are only human too there is a
range of interpretations available on
the data that we have i think it's very
important that we're really
practical and realistic about science in
an
at this kind of environment of
uncertainty and we have to balance the
cost of lockdown the cost of these
measures
against the cost of the disease and the
department of health's own figures show
that lockdown's been more expensive than
the disease
and very quickly because we are running
out of time do you think that boris
johnson should listen a bit more to his
chancellor then
well i want the two of them to succeed
as a team i've got great admiration
for them both in a sense what we need is
boris back with his bounce with his mojo
he's got a great chancellor in rishi and
i support them both
okay uh and just finally there were
reports this morning that paul
daycare the former editor of the daily
mail
critic of the bbc is boris johnson's top
choice
for the job of ofcom chairman is that an
appointment you'd welcome
of course it is yes i'd be delighted and
of course i'd like to see charles moore
go in as chairman of the bbc i think
this would be great news and i think
anyone suggesting we
we were somehow appointing our preferred
people needs to look at the record of
others who've been appointed to these
roles
and try to be a bit again more realistic
about politics and policy and who should
be
appointed by governments why would it be
great news then
well because they're conservatives and
they would they might actually start to
look at the way
the media functions and ensure there's
some impartiality i can
i can assure you that from my point of
view time and again during interviews
i felt that there was a consensus
thought on the side of the broadcaster
which was not on the side of moderate
mainstream conservatism so
i look forward to them perhaps being
appointed and being a bit more
conservative and pragmatic in what is
reported